all right so we just got to Hollywood
we're going to the it niebolt house
Hollywood I don't know if it's like a
haunted house or just like a type of
thing where you take pictures but we are
gonna go check it out
[Music]
this is a recreation of the 29 niebolt
house from the it movie and we're gonna
be checking this out in a little bit if
you guys aren't familiar with the book
it this is where the Lucky seven has one
of the earliest confrontations with
penny wise so I'm excited to see what's
in store for us
[Music]
we're here at the side of the knee volt
house this is where Eddie encounters the
leper who crawls out from under the
porch like you see these people standing
over here these are these are basically
the lepers and I'm basically Eddie we
don't have our own Jake Paul team ten
house but I'm thinking after they're
done using this for promoting the movie
we can just move into this house with
some other youtubers so I like that the
windows are really nice and board it up
that way when you're editing you have no
sense of time practically it's a set so
it's interchangeable so he knows the
best line of ever skipped
[Music]
[Music]
you're gonna you're getting the first
look at Zach's brand-new house which is
cool
Dakota's log is with in my video we're
going
[Music]
I can't see anything
come on
rule number one do not touch the
monsters and rule number two don't lose
me and don't open any doors without my
permission okay
got it yeah sweet okay follow me
well there anyone behind you okay this
is all of us don't split up okay
welcome to the it experience this is my
boat house in Hollywood California this
is where it lives once we go through
this hallway it's up to me to guide you
out of here okay
my name is Georgie hiya Georgie here
come on
this is too late you will get hurt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guys over here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
buying thank you guys for coming
luckily we all made it why I love you we
are definitely buying that house no I
think with a little bit upkeep I think
it's I think it's good to go
think of the views we could get living
in there there's a lot of benefit to
this house which are really unexpected
they were central air
there was closet there was one room they
had three closets in that was like
that's great real estate you know that
is pretty good real estate you're not
gonna find something like that around
this these parts you know it's just too
expensive this is a great deal there's a
lot just the one place doesn't have a
roach or two running around nowadays
yeah it just needs to be painted black
yeah
[Music]
it has I think plenty of rooms you know
I think all the older occupants were
really nice to get the house in good
shape he's Craigslist house what do you
expect I really liked it I think you
guys are gonna make great videos in
there I also like the you know the
bathtub full of intestines I hear it's a
great exfoliant and moisturizer and
that's a great space in LA it's right in
all the action its Rohn being somewhere
over here dude the certain Church of
Scientology's right across the street so
we should like it might please another
haunted house in but you guys are really
happy about all the little Georgie's but
if those little shits don't pay rent
they're out of that as a horror house
it's excellent
I didn't want to be there I was
terrified I clicked on everything that I
could
so AJ's a no-go on this mill go this one
hope you guys enjoyed that tour of the
it's niebolt house let me know in the
comments if you think that we should buy
this house and live in it remember to
subscribe to see Z's world for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Music]
you know my favorite part of vlogging in
the Hard Rock Cafe what is English me